Now that we have our tools set up, now let's look at how we might begin the storyboarding
process inside of Unreal Engine.
So let's look at how we create this first storyboard.
So to get started, we want to create a board.
So we have this drop-down option here, and we want to start storyboarding.
Again, if you can't see these options, it may be because you've not got the correct
plugins enabled.
So you just want to restart your editor.
Again, if your plugins aren't there, and then select Start Storyboarding to create
a new board sequence asset.
So additionally, we can also import the image sequences directly to Unreal.
But for this purpose, we're just going to drop down from the cinematic and start storyboarding.
So in starting out with a new board sequence, there are a few settings you want to change
here that can modify.
And then once you get familiar with those, you can dial them in for whatever you would
like for your given project.
So we want to adjust the root board for your project.
So the name and path you want to set those into the desired locations.
And then in the naming conventions tab, you have the global settings here, and then also
the board naming convention fields.
So however you would like to set those up for your projects needs, you can use those.
And then we also have the shot plane and the camera naming within these different headings
here.
And then starting out, it is OK to leave these as defaults.
But as you get more familiar with these tools, you'll be able to dial them into exactly what
you need.
So you have a couple more options here in the sequence and sequence r tabs.
If you do want to update any of these settings here.
So that's it.
Thank you.
Bye.